à quoi ça sert le microbiote le
microbiote c'est ces 100000 milliards de
microbes qu'on a là dans les intestins
ça peut faire peur bah oui les microbes
on nous a appris à nous en méfier
surtout ceux qu'on a dans ce coinl
ensuite on nous a dit qu'il y en avait
des bons et des mauvais le même microbe
il peut être bon s'il est au bon endroit
et mauvais il est au mauvais endroit une
bactérie quand elle est dans le colon
elle peut aider à la digestion par
exemple mais la même bactérie dans la
vessie ça donne une infection urinaire
par contre si tout le monde reste à sa
place tout va bien le microbiote
intestinal c'est un peu comme une
société dans laquelle tout le monde a sa
place et une entreprise dans laquelle
chacun a son rôle avec un objectif
commun notre santé et oui parce que
notre microbiote intestinale il ne nous
sert pas qu'à fabriquer du caca il a
plusieurs rôles très pointus dans le
domaine de la digestion bien sûr et
c'est déjà pas mal mais pas seulement il
joue aussi un rôle important au niveau
de notre système immunitaire il nous
protège contre un certain nombre de
maladies qui ont rien à voir avec nos
intestins au premier abord et il est
même capable de communiquer avec notre
cerveau et d'influencer notre
comportement